attack when he sell without selling and
I think in that way the compounding will
happen faster than the revenue would
have otherwise increased if you started
trying to make the money fast and so the
longer you can delay that the better
it's going to be and then you can
understand why all these guys play the
infinite game of never even wanting to
do that right hook because it's like but
next year I'm going to have five times
the audience and then a year later
they're like but next year I'm gonna
have five times the audience because as
soon as you shoot your shot you
dramatically decrease the Goodwill I
know Gary's got jab jab jab right hook
just a personal observation that I've
had is that you can go give give give
give give give get you don't even have
to ask people to start handing things to
you